[Musique]
mélanie nous a donc rejoint en plateau
vous avez deux activités à proposer un
atelier manuel eme journée sportive
c'est ça alors plusieurs sortes de
talents vont être mis à profit ce
week-end pour la première vous allez
pouvoir mais les peintures et sciences
la commanderie des templiers fait de la
peinture connecter ce samedi grâce à des
peintures conductrice vous allez donner
vie à vos descend les rendant lumineux
et sonores c'est le tout dernier atelier
autour de l'image et du son
l'exposition perception illusions se
termine ce week-end alors l'atelier dure
une heure et s'adresse aux enfants à
partir de 6 ans l'entrée est libre mais
c'est sur réservation et donc sur la
duration donc le bandeau qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran pour pouvoir
s'inscrire et pour ceux qui voudraient
terminé ses vacances d'hiver en
extérieur la vitesse va être de mise du
côté de trappes
alors c'est fini de jouer avec aux
pilotes des coups sur sa voiture à
pédales ou pourquoi pas comme je le
faisais enfants avec l'aspirateur de mes
parents on passe aux choses sérieuses
sur le circuit jean-pierre beltoise de
trappes avec le formula kids l'école de
pilotage ce dimanche c'est à dire le 4
mars les jeunes de 7 à 18 ans vont
pouvoir prendre une leçon de conduite
sur de vraies voitures de sport pour les
plus jeunes c'est jusqu'à 12 ans ce sera
au volant d'une smart roadster et les
plus grands eux pourront même tester une
planche sauveteurs regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc les initiations qui dure une heure
et demie le site internet pour pouvoir
s'inscrire s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup mes amis pour ses idées
sorties l'heure environ 3 plutôt faire
de la peinture ou sur le circuit ce week
end circuit et paris-nice commission
retrouvera alors merci en tout cas pour
ses idées sorties dédié aux plus jeunes
cela